junko I am a chronic excuse maker how do
I stop making excuses and get things
done
the chronic excuse maker
have you stopped making excuses this is
actually pretty simple and I said it the
other day and you have to realize you
have to know you have to accept that all
your excuses are lies their lies all of
them think about the things that you
tell yourself the lies you used to
rationalize taking the easy road taking
the easy road and leaving discipline
behind think about them you don't have
time that's a lie you don't have support
that's a lie you don't have the
equipment or the gear lies you don't you
don't know the best way who cares that's
a lie or you're too old or you're too
young of course you're too old or too
young lie and there's you're too busy
sure you are
that's why and you're too tired or
you're too sore or you're just plain not
feeling it lies lies lies and the list
goes on and on and on and it doesn't
stop if you don't make it stop so
recognize recognize the excuses are not
valid they are they're trumped up
they're conjured up they're fabricated
their lies and how do you stop the lies
you stop the lies with the truth the
truth the truth will set you free the
truth will stand and the truth will
deliver you from procrastination and
laziness and the downward spiral that
comes with a lack of discipline so don't
believe the lies believe the truth and
the truth is you have time you have the
skill you have the knowledge and the
support and the willpower and the
discipline to get it done so cast out
the lies burn them down and listen to
the truth then live the truth and go out
and get it done